Eric what happened last night well first
of all let's get this out of the way
six-foot and a very unfortunate 207 all
right and I promise to behave but last
night was a lot of people were seeing
this and I was really curious to see
that pole that they Club and put out
there because if 70 percent of us out
there believe that this is a setback and
they might be right in saying that I I
think that there's a culmination of
about 20 years of an underlying problem
that I think manifests itself last night
on the field so this is our opportunity
to fix it
more so than anything else what would
you do let's say I made you president of
USA soccer what would you do look I
think you're teasing me because that
actually has been entertained I've
actually been asked to entertain that
idea and I'm strongly considering I'm
not gonna lie but I think the
relationship that exists right now with
US soccer and I guess all of the
components it needs to be a little bit
more defined I mean I think for this kid
crystal istic kind of proved that this
is a malfunctioning system this is a kid
who comes out of nowhere Hershey
Pennsylvania at the age of 16 and
recognizes that he needed to get out of
this country to get good and that's
that's a problem that's that's a massive
problem but this I guess the lasting
image that I have right now is that kids
face our best soccer player done that
we've ever had and I know you're gonna
have landed on the show in a bit and
that might be a tough one for him to
swallow but this kid is the best soccer
player we've ever had and he's not going
to get to play in a World Cup and that's
just sad do we not have the talent or
know how to develop the talent well it's
a great question I think the talent is
out there I and that's another part of
the problem yesterday what I would do is
if I were in charge of this thing and as
I think the when in this country the
moment of the discovery of the talent is
usually
the moment where the destruction starts
to happen and that's that's a big
problem because in this country I would
argue that the talents of the abilities
of our players now exceeds the knowledge
of the coaching and if when that happens
our players are not either getting the
right information or being one of that
opportunity to grow and become the
player that they're that they have the
potential to be so developing is is a
weird word
because I think Steven made a great
point a couple of minutes ago about
geographically how big our country is
it's a cultural problem because you
can't you can't ask the kid from New
Jersey to be just like the kid from
Florida and the kid from Florida to be
the same as the kid in Dallas and the
kid that lives right on the Tijuana
San Diego border we're trying to spit
out robots as opposed to allow these
kids to to be who they are and to
express themself on the field and it's
it's a big problem it's hard to get your
arms around it because the country is so
big and there's that pay-to-play
feeling lingering that that a lot of
people feel that only the the entitle
get to play this game and it's it's
something that needs to get fixed I
think there is a solution but we haven't
we never really had a plan in a long
time but is there the possibility Eric
we're just going to be mediocre in this
sport that that's what that's our lot in
life we're just gonna be mediocre in
World Cup soccer competition if you
really want to be honest I think we've
married ourselves in mediocrity and in
that sense I think that if we want to
you know go a different route we are the
sleeping giant but we're our own worst
enemy we're the one hitting this news
button that we could be a massive force
in this game because we do have the
talent but I think some of the
components of our infrastructure let us
down and I think I think when you get
landed on I mean he's a great guy to ask
this to because here's a kid that comes
out of Redlands and a lot of gone a lot
of people by surprise but ask him about
his progression and and how that
happened for him at the age of 16 17 18
when he started to figure out I'm pretty
good at this how far can I take it I
think he had he was fortunate he had
some good people around it he's Eric
Wynalda Fox Soccer a knows former team
USA player but I look at this and it's
Trinidad and Tobago which is about the
size of San Diego or population 1.7
million like it's the it's it's the
United States against San Diego and San
Diego one come on yeah it's a rough
thing you swallow and aesthetically
doesn't look good but I mean let's ask
ourselves this let's put our all-star
team for baseball okay let's take our
best players and let's put them up
against the Dominican Republic and see
how they do it's not gonna be the
outcome you would expect and that might
be the same even now for Japan or Korea
or Cuba for that matter they baseball
and and I mean you call it the World
Series yeah all the soccer you know
people will say well it's not really the
World Series it's it's just the United
States you didn't defeat the world and
in our sport what what surprises people
is that countries you know the size of
San Diego I can get their act together
on one night on one occasion and and
have a have this kind of result and it's
a punch in the face it's a kick in the
gut it's this is bad I mean there's a
lot of people out there very upset but I
think the light at the end of the tunnel
is a country like France for example
they got knocked out of the 94 World Cup
people forget that but they recognized
that it was a time for change they
needed to fix things internally and four
years later they were world champions
beating Brazil three nothing in a final
so the opportunities there I think this
this to use my previous analogy this is
a wake-up call but why does Team USA the
women's team do well dominate and the
men don't well I think they're that the
infrastructure of the collegiate system
actually works for them because most of
the countries that that on the on the
women's side they're not as organized as
we are so and when you got a bunch of
women who are competing at the
collegiate level of Division one level
and it's a very high level of soccer
they can come in a fitter they can come
in with a better idea tactically of how
to address games like that maybe we're
seeing the rest of the
country or that's the world I should say
catching up with the likes of what
Brazil is now doing for their women's
program China is now kind of figuring it
out but Japan is already there and so is
Germany so too I think for us as a
country the women have figured it out
because they are extremely talented but
they did have that that infrastructure
that worked in their favor the
collegiate system unfortunately right
now for soccer and the men's side
sometimes gets in the way and there's a
lot of politics that create more
problems than help would you replace
Bruce Arena is the manager well not
immediately we got no we got no reason
to to do that at this point I think he
was put in a tough spot we were already
in the hole and I think you know if this
isn't your in Clinton small business and
Bruce arenas fault
a lot of this might fall on our current
presidents in yo Galati but I do think
that the players just just really failed
to perform in a crucial moment and
they've let themselves down you got to
keep in mind we Bobby wood doesn't score
against Honduras yeah about a month ago
you know we're in a worse spot than this
so we've been in trouble for a while
I'll talk to you in four years Eric well
this was three years ago Pauley I'm
sorry about the 238 text message that
was really uncalled for but you know I
tried to I tried to be a little bit more
together today the last time we spoke I
was way too fired up but I did since the
last time we talked and I got two more
kids thanks buddy good to talk to you
Eric Wynalda former USA soccer player
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you